Steve what is Serendipity what is
Serendipity yeah well one thing it is is
a world famous ice cream parer in New
York City are you familiar with it I'm
not is it still open uh to my knowledge
it is it's uh world famous for amazing
ice cream concoctions but the to answer
your question more specifically I think
by Serendipity you mean wonderful things
happening kind of out of the blue sure
yeah yeah without planning the opposite
of planning and do you believe in
Serendipity yeah I'd say my life is
pretty much serendipitous yes how do you
open yourself up to
Serendipity oh that's an interesting
question sort of an existential question
I think what happens is Serendipity
either happens or it doesn't happen to
you I don't think it's like falling in
love you know you can try your best to
make something happen in your love life
say but if it's going to happen there's
this ineffable thing called chemistry
which allows it to happen and I think
the same kind of uh operating principles
relate to Serendipity in your life sure
I got a great gal for you she's studying
to do this and then you meet the person
and it's not there's nothing there and
then right the person who's totally
wrong for you and yeah it happens
right do you think an artist can hurt
themselves in some sense or their career
by not believing in
Serendipity well I mean I I can't speak
for other people but I believe that
whatever you you believe you put out
into the universe okay sort of a karmic
thing so if if you're open to
serendipitous good things randomly
happening to you in life
they most likely will
happen so it's it's being like um almost
like
receptical for things or or a vessel
somehow for for interesting things to
happen stopping to talk to people on the
street maybe you've been warned don't
speak to strangers but sometimes amazing
things can come from that yeah well
actually uh this is the Story of My Life
basically um the the best some of the
best things that ever happened to me in
my life came out totally serendipitously
out of the blue completely out of the
blue do you have any examples of some
serendipitous uh instances in your life
I'll I'll give you uh a primary one okay
so uh I graduated from the University of
Miami
Florida and then got a scholarship to
law
school and I went to law school school
for that the first
year I decided that law was not for me
so I tell my
mother uh who was a single mom at the
time my dad had passed away earlier I
said to my mom uh I'm going to drop out
of law school I'm not going back for the
second year okay and uh I'm going to New
York to do what I've always wanted to do
which was write comic books
okay so my mother being a Jewish mother
and I being her only son and her being a
single mom uh my mother was not too
happy with that decision as you might
imagine but I was confirmed in this is
what I was going to
do so my mother says to me uh well you
know we live here in Miami Beach and
it's very warm you're going to go to New
York and it's very cold hold there right
now you don't have any warm clothes and
I said you know Mom you're you're right
so I get this idea in my head I'm going
to go to
Macy's and buy some warm clothes now I
had probably been in Macy's twice before
that in my life I don't know what
impelled me to go to
Macy's uh but before I go there my
mother also says you know it's very
expensive
to live in in New York City uh so and
you don't have that much money saved up
from various little jobs and whatever so
she says to me you know how how are you
going to afford living in New
York and I said I don't know Mom but I'm
going to do
it so here comes the
Serendipity and when I tell this story
to people they they're just Gob smacked
by it some at Macy's maybe the third
thir time in my life in the store and
I'm at this
circular uh clothing display you know
where you can turn the rack and it comes
around right so I'm looking at the small
amount of warm clothes I have there on
this circular display and I turn it to
look at some of the other stuff and
suddenly I look up and I see there's a
woman on the other side of the circular
rack and I go oh I'm I'm very sorry you
were looking at clothes and I moved them
away from you okay so she
laughed and we started
talking and I tell the woman uh you know
I'm I'm buying these clothes you know we
get a little conversation we're buying
these clo I'm buying these clothes
because I'm going to New York uh to
write comic books and she laughs right
and she says to me this she says um so
where are you going to live in New York
and I say uh I'm not really sure and
then she says to me me this she says I
happen to own a rent controlled
apartment on East 79th Street at Second
Avenue and next week I'm going to Europe
for a
year would you like to
suas my
apartment now you tell me wow what are
the
odds a billion to one that that would
have happened but that is how
Serendipity to the max Serendipity
squared got me to New York City and when
you went home to tell Mom what did she
say oh first she she didn't believe it
she could not believe it but then when
it was confirmed to her by this woman
you know that this was indeed happening
my mother gave up in terms of trying to
get me to go back to law school cuz she
just figured well you know I wanted this
and somehow the universe gave it to me
so if that isn't one of the most
incredible serendipitous stories I've
ever heard you
know it's fantastic I was just curious
what type of law were you practicing
were you sorry well I was just in the
first year of law school and you don't
even know what you're gonna
uh practice yet okay you just got to get
through that first year which is always
considered the toughest year which I did
do and it's usually considered if you
get through that first year the rest is
like a breeze so for me that decide not
to go back was not a happy to anybody
but me a happy decision you have many
stories about serendipity one of which
is right there in your hands and I'm
wondering if you can hold up that
beautiful cover for us yeah gorgeous and
this has become your life's work yeah
and that is a another instance of
serendipity yeah okay so uh you see the
the book on camera okay I'll put it down
now um all right so in the mid
1980s uh my wife and I moved to the
state of Maine where we had a very good
set of mutual friends
and uh I was uh the owner of an
advertising agency in Princeton New
Jersey prior to moving to to
Maine and then when I sold my Ad Agency
in Jersey and moved to Maine I
reestablished my a agency there in the
town of Auburn
Maine and so uh my very good friend who
uh had a lot of connection
in that
area uh started giving me uh names of
his clients for his accounting firm and
said you know they could use some
advertising there was very there was no
advertising agency up there in the mid
80s until I got up there right so
uh here's what
happens I go to see a new potential
client named Cody's oldfashioned ice
cream
now this may sound like small town stuff
in Maine but Yankee Magazine which is
like the Arbiter of all things cool in
New England called Cody's ice cream
quote unquote the best damn ice cream in
New England so you know they were
serious ice cream company right so I go
to the office of uh Nancy Cody
uh co-owner with her husband Roland of
uh Cody's oldfashioned ice cream and I'm
looking around and I see in her office
these fabulous pen and ink
drawings uh you know put up around the
office and I look at them and I say uh
hey uh whose art is that and NY says
that's my son Dan and I'll tell you what
Steve if you use Dan as the artist on
all of our advertising I'll give you the
account so not being stupid I
immediately said yes plus I Lov the
artwork that I saw okay so week later I
go and I visit Dan at his
home and we get
talking and uh I tell Dan about you know
how how I've been dabbling in comic
books my whole life and how much I love
them and he said said man I would really
really really love to work on a comic
book with you in addition to doing the
advertising so he says you got any ideas
what could we work on now I have to go
back I got to do a little flashback
couple of days before I go to meet Nancy
and then Dan uh I'm unpacking from our
move from Jersey to Maine and
uh this suitcase that I had a lot of
stuff in uh falls on the floor cracks
open and one piece of paper flies out
it's a one-page synopsis of a
story called
Zen now what what was the backstory of
this synopsis when I was living in uh
New York City for about a year and a
half as I mentioned earlier
I started writing comic books and I
mostly wrote comic book stories for
these black and white sort of like
horror magazines with titles like
Nightmare and psycho things like that
witches witches
tales and what would happen is you would
hand off a
synopsis to the publisher okay and then
artists would come in to the office in
Midtown Manhattan visit the publisher
and look at the various story ideas and
if they liked an idea then you could
write the story and it would be
published right and that happened to me
with a number of stories but never with
this story called Zen so before I left
New York the publisher gave me back that
one-page synopsis which came with me to
Maine which fell out of the cracked open
box that I presented to Dan and thus Zen
was born once again if that isn't
Serendipity then you know I don't know
what
is